lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
analizar un negocio bastante común voy a
entrar al negocio del jugo de naranja en
esta columna he escrito los galones de
jugo de naranja que voy a producir cada
semana todo esto está en términos
semanales esos son mis costos fijos
yo estoy asumiendo que me va a costar
mil dólares el producir el jugo podemos
decir que a lo mejor todos los pagos de
una máquina robótica para hacer jugos y
que para efectos de simplicidad vamos a
asumir que puede producir todo el jugo
de naranja que yo quiera
y quizás esto implica tener algunos
empleados que pasarán parte de su tiempo
operando esta máquina
todos estos son costos fijos el costo de
tener la máquina y el contrato de los
empleados que la van a operar que va a
ser durante un año son cosas que voy a
tener durante bastante tiempo por eso
estos gastos están fijos y van a durar
al menos un año estos son mis costos
variables aquellos costos que están
relacionados con la cantidad de jugo que
quiero producir básicamente va a ser el
costo de las naranjas que voy a
necesitar para hacer el jugo obviamente
si no producimos jugo pues no vamos a
necesitar ninguna naranja si producimos
1000 galones de jugo de naranja
tendremos que gastar 500 dólares en
comprar los naranjas y transportarlas a
donde está nuestra fábrica si quiere
producir 2.000 galones mi costo variable
será de 850 dólares noten que la
diferencia con el anterior fue de sólo
350 dólares para los primeros 1000
galones el costo variable fue de 500
para los siguientes 1000 el costo de
sólo 750 lo que sucede aquí es que a lo
mejor tengo alguna negociación con
algunos de mis proveedores y si les digo
que les estoy comprando mucho más pues
que me permitan negociar el precio más
barato y quizá es lo mismo ocurre con
las personas que hacen el transporte de
las naranjas
les digo mira me estás transportando
bastantes naranjas porque no me das un
mejor precio y vemos que conforme van
aumentando la cantidad de naranjas el
precio va siendo mejor el incremento de
aquí acá es solo de 250 y después
comienza a ser un poco más caro de nuevo
lo que está pasando es que el estar
comprando yo más y más naranjas de los
distribuidores locales obtengo un
negocio muy bueno pero una vez que lo
sobrepasó o que ellos ya no tienen lo
suficiente para vender me los tengo que
alejarme para comprar más naranjas donde
quizás los proveedores sean más caros
podría sobrepasar la capacidad de los
proveedores más baratos por eso es que
mi costo variable se incrementa una vez
que pasó los 5.000 galones de jugo y el
costo total obviamente es la suma de los
costos fijos más los costos variables si
yo quiero producir 9 mil galones de jugo
me costará 4 mil 360 dólares
vamos a calcular y aquí estoy usando una
hoja de cálculo vamos a encontrar el
costo fijo promedio
y no queremos dividirlo entre 0
recuerden que el costo fijo promedio el
costo variable promedio y el costo total
promedio son cada uno de estos costos
divididos entre el número total de jugo
producido podemos verlo como el costo
por galón así que viendo el costo fijo
promedio por galón para calcularlo vamos
a escribir un igual para que sepa la
hoja de cálculo que vamos a hacer una
operación esto va a ser igual a mi costo
fijo dividido entre mi número de galones
y aquí están las celdas donde se
encuentran esos valores
y esto le damos enter y ese es el valor
un dólar por galón el promedio del costo
variable por galón
va a ser mi costo variable dividido
entre el número de galones
de igual manera que lo hicimos en la
celda anterior damos enter y este es el
resultado en este caso a producir un
galón de jugo me cuesta 50 centavos de
naranjas y esto incluye el costo de
transporte
y ahora el costo total promedio va a ser
la suma de estos 2
o podemos hacerlo de otra manera podemos
haber dicho que esto es igual a nuestro
costo total dividido entre el número de
galones el costo total dividido entre el
número total de galones de cualquier
manera obtenemos el mismo resultado
quizás haga un vídeo explicando la
matemática de esto oa lo mejor ustedes
deberían explorarlo por ustedes mismos
ahora el costo marginal este va a ser
igual al cambio en el costo al cambio en
el costo total dividido entre el cambio
de galones de jugó así que es el cambio
en el costo total será esto 1500 menos
1000 ese es nuestro cambio en el costo
total dividido entre el cambio en el
número de galones y nos quedan 50
centavos ahora vamos a copiar todas
estas columnas y lo bonito de las hojas
de cálculo es que puedo llenar todas
estas celdas copiando las fórmulas
relativas que acabo de hacer y así
obtengo todos estos resultados de una
sola vez vamos a llenar las celdas
sin formato y lo genial de aquí que es
algo que ya tenía configurado es
graficar todos estos elementos de aquí
esa es una gráfica que vimos en un vídeo
anterior cuando hablábamos de desarrollo
de software este era nuestro costo fijo
este es nuestro control variable que
aumenta conforme producimos más y más y
nuestro costo total es la suma de los
dos tomamos el costo variable le
agregamos los mil dólares del costo fijo
y obtenemos esta curva de que lo que
obtuvimos aquí al graficar todo esto
tenemos el costo marginal el costo
promedio variable y el costo promedio
fijo no he programado el costo fijo
total aquí pero es la diferencia entre
el costo total y el costo variable ahora
pensemos en qué es lo que está
sucediendo acá veamos primero el costo
marginal que nos ayuda a ver esta
narrativa sobre lo que está pasando las
primeras tendencias que compramos eran
caras no éramos un productor mayor pero
conforme fuimos incrementando la
producción las siguientes naranjas el
precio se hizo más barato
conforme pasamos de las naranjas
necesarias para ser 1000 galones a las
naranjas necesarias para hacer 2.000
galones de jugo
nuestro costo marginal bajo ahora somos
un comprador mayor y esas naranjas
incrementales son más baratas para
nosotros y cuando pasamos a los 3.000
galones se hace aún más barato y después
tenemos que ir a conseguir naranjas
fuera de nuestro mercado local por lo
que esas naranjas incrementales van
siendo más caras como podemos ver en
este costo marginal y no tan claro en
nuestro costo variable vemos que esto se
atenúa hasta cierto punto recuerden que
el promedio del costo variable en
cualquiera de estos puntos se ha
calculado varias veces va a ser igual a
el costo variable dividido entre el
número de galones producidos
otra manera de ver esto es como lo vimos
en un vídeo anterior en donde si tomamos
cualquiera de estos puntos el promedio
del costo variable es la pendiente entre
ese punto y el origen mientras que el
costo marginal es la pendiente entre ese
punto y el punto anterior por lo que el
costo marginal solo va a mostrar que
tanto de esos incrementos están costando
y es por eso que aquí el costo marginal
captura el comportamiento del costo de
las naranjas para el siguiente
incremento de 1000 galones de jugo
cuánto va a ser el costo en las naranjas
necesarias y obviamente el promedio del
costo total al principio tenemos nuestro
costo fijo que se reparte demasiado pero
conforme vamos a incrementar el número
de galones producidos nuestros costos
fijos se van a repartir aún más por lo
que voy a tener esta brecha entre la
curva amarilla y la curva naranja que es
nuestro costo fijo promedio que se va
convirtiendo en algo más reducido cada
vez